so when you started off you were doing
the the sort of objective news stuff
and then obviously you moved into kelly
file in which case your perspective was
allowed to come out a little bit more so
what was the difference between doing
those two things because we see now this
complete merger of the two
and obviously you look at cnn where they
promote chris cuomo as an objective news
anchor or don lemon as an objective
news anchor but you made a pretty stark
division in your own career from
objective news reporter to
megyn kelly of the kelly file where your
perspective was incredibly clear and you
were pretty open about it
what was the difference between those
two roles well i mean i think that you
can
you can maintain your journalistic cred
um by being
open and honest about what you're
opining on and when it's opinion and
what you won't opine on you know i don't
understand being
calling yourself a credible news anchor
and going out there and openly ripping
on president trump and everything he
does every night and calling him a bad
man an evil and a racist
like that's not reporting that's a
that's pure opinion
and i feel like you go there and you you
can no longer call yourself a straight
news reporter
however i was never hesitant to call
somebody who is you know driving
200 miles an hour down the highway while
a woman's pushing her baby in a baby
stroller an idiot
and i think that sort of is what
distinguished me from
some other people on the air i would
take more editorial risks
like that on what i considered common
sense issues
that weren't incredibly divisive and
what my my main commitment was
was to the facts and when people veered
offline when it came to the facts
i always hit them in the head it was
like get back stay right stay in the
right lane and that's how this
discussion is going to go
and so i think i mean i'm seeing it now
with the black lives matter narrative
like
if you just stick with the facts like
what are the numbers
when it comes to police shootings what
what are the racial divisions what is
the what are the crime statistics
people freak out but they just want you
to say what they want you to say
but as you know facts don't care about
your feelings is somebody really smart
always says and um i'm in that lane like
i i don't care if you don't like it
these are the facts and we can't have a
reasonable argument unless we stick to
that
so i think it sort of stuck out a bit as
like she's different and she you know
she's saying she's defending the police
it's like well
if the facts are defensive of them then
yes i guess so i'm defending the facts
anyway that's sort of how it went and i
always tried to hold on to my
objectivity like
even when trump was coming up and uh he
was very controversial a lot of
republicans didn't like him i was never
out there night after night being like
he's terrible how could the republicans
do this
i would just report on him fairly then i
defended him on a lot of the
bs being thrown at him and then when he
did something really
you know crazy like saying judge
curielle couldn't decide his trump
university case because he was of
hispanic heritage
i hit him you know like as a lawyer i
always felt comfortable giving my
opinion so anyway it's
it's a bit of a hybrid approach but i
would submit
it is it looks nothing like what we're
seeing
now in the media with people like don
lemon
who's just a joke and chris cuomo who's
much more worried about his muscles than
he is about the facts
i just can't watch cnn anymore and i'm
angry about it because i used to like
cnn but
those days are gone did you know that
every like on this video creates one
additional glorious leftist here don't
ask me why that's called science
to take advantage of this amazing
opportunity just hit the like button